Speaker 1: Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell, or as
he's better known, Mike Pillow, believes that
Wal-Mart is trying to cancel him because they
decided to pull his products from their stores.
Lindell was told on a Zoom call with Wal-Mart
officials about two weeks ago that the retailer
would no longer be selling Mypillow in their
stores and would instead exclusively be selling
them on the Walmart website. So that's
a me sounds like a half measure because
they're willing to sell his product still just not
in the retail stores, only in the online stores.
And I think we can go further and
maybe call it a quarter measure because
if the idea is you want to disassociate with this
guy because he's become a controversial figure.
Well, he's been that way for well over a year now,
like it's been well over a year since he's gone
down the rabbit hole of spewing election fraud.
Conspiracy theories and plenty of other chains
have already broken ties with him like Bed, Bath
and Beyond. Wayfair, Kohl's. They've all said,
we have. We want nothing to do with this guy.
So why is Walmart only now saying, you know,
he's really gone off the deep end, we want to
start to cut ties with him? Well, Mike Lindell
is acting like this is a major travesty. And
he went on Lindell TV's own TV Broadcasting
Network to complain about the whole thing.
Speaker 7: It's been the same radio if you're
if that's what you're talking about at Walmart
forever. We've been ten years. And he goes,
he go. And I said, So what does after go? Well,
we put this new rating and you have to be 84.
And I go, What? When did you put
this in? You ready, everybody?
He goes, Over two years ago. I said, Wait a
minute. So you put it here over two years ago,
and now you're saying you can't carry my show two
plus years later because of our rating, when we
have sold $20 million of my pillows a year and
more, maybe upwards of 40 million in your store.
And you're telling me that you put this thing in
two and a half years ago and I said, I get it,
you're canceling us now. I just smirk on his face
and I slam the computer. Disgusting. Shame on you,
Walmart. Shame on you. You know, just
because you thought you could wait until now
for the American people, for the people of this
country to sit there and do a slow cancel out,
it's just as bad. You should have just
done it on day one when I when I stood
up with the evidence out there. That's what
they should have done. Brandon, you know,
they're just they're cowards. They're disgusting.
Speaker 1: And and you got to love how the right
wing in this country are always so eager to use
their buzzwords, even when they don't apply it all
like the new one they've been settling on recently
as groomer. Whenever we say that teachers should
be allowed to teach their students that gay people
exist in society, and sometimes men marry men
and women marry women. And that's all well and
good. Well, the right will call that grooming,
even though obviously that term does not apply in
that situation. It's the same with cancel culture
like Walmart is not canceling you. Mike Lindell
They're just making a business decision that they
think is right for them and their consumers
and they have every right to do that. It's
not canceling or anything like that. And when it
comes to the voter fraud narrative, stuff that
Mike Lindell loves to push, ever since this all
started after the 2020 election, we've wondered
who actually believes this and who doesn't
believe this. Like Rudy Giuliani, for example,
Sidney Powell, many of these Republican senators
and congresspeople. I don't actually think that
they believe. The voter fraud stuff. I think that
they're just paying lip service to it to get on
Donald Trump's good side. Mike Lindell On the
other hand, this guy definitely believes that
he has to believe it. I mean, he had a decent
enough reputation before all this started,
before he decided to hitch his wagon to the Trump
train. He had a successful business going. Now,
as pillows are being being taken out of stores all
across America, and he's being sued by Dominion
voting systems for well over $1,000,000,000. And,
you know, he's had such a fall from grace, like
he definitely didn't have a material advantage
to doing this. He definitely believes this voter
fraud stuff. And it's sad to see in a sense, but
maybe you can also say he has what's coming to
him. All right. That's going to do it for today's
episode of The David Pakman show. I am going to be
hosting today's bonus show as well. So if you want
to check that out, make sure to become a member or
a patron. You can go to join Pacman dot com or
you can go to Patrick Incom, slash David Pakman
show and sign up at the $5 level to everyone
who's not going to be watching the bonus show.
I'll see you next time I do this. And to all
the members and patrons, be on the bonus.